here's what's happening the goal is to
have some sort of dinky little light
pre-pass ranger up and running as
quickly as possible
i'll start the timer and try to bang
this out over the course of a day
now it's been about a million years
since i was a real game programmer so
i'll probably get a whole bunch of
things wrong
3d engines at a high level aren't that
complex
they tend to have some nice abstractions
around a few key concepts like
you need to abstract away the state of
the renderer there's a bunch of things
that are
reasonably common like having a camera
so that we can easily view the scene
from various angles
a mesh model drawable type of thing
representing objects in the scene
a material or shader for representing
things like
how they should look these are all
pretty common patterns
then it needs to understand materials
like what order to draw things that sort
of stuff
there's a bunch of crap i'm
intentionally skipping like visibility
system
loading pretty much a million things but
that's the basics the rough plan
is get something on the screen start
getting some of those parts working
like the camera the mesh material try
getting those parts working together
and getting the various passes in in
more technical terms this means that we
need to
initialize webgl get our abstractions
working that would be like mesh
shader camera get fbos working or frame
buffer objects
and then finally get the various stages
of a light pre-pass renderer in place
like
zed pre-pass and normals light buffer
generation
and the forward opaque paths the first
thing we need to do is start a new
project
so i'll just go make a new directory
let's call this webgl
one day 3d engine nice and
straightforward name
and we'll need a few files too so i'll
just go ahead and make the index.html
and main.js that we'll be working from
so traditionally i've always used
directx or other things
never had much fondness for opengl in
fact i find it
really really hard to work with and 3js
is a really good 3d library so i've
never had much reason to use webgl
directly
the first thing we need to do is
initialize webgl and we'll just start by
searching for a tutorial
i always find mozilla's docs to be super
helpful so we'll head straight there
looking over the code in here this looks
pretty simple just a few lines of code
and we should be up and running
in c plus this would be way more code
just
because but in javascript it looks like
it's just going to be a breeze
in our code i've just created this basic
renderer class that i'll be flashing out
over time and i just copied the
initialization code wholesale right into
it
and like the docs say once i run it i
get a big black box
so we're off to a good start maybe
probably
one thing to note is that i want to use
webgl too and not have to deal with the
crap ton of extensions and other bs that
webgl1 has to deal with
so in the code that just means we need
to change this line here from webgl to
webgl2
the first thing i want to do is get
something on the screen so we're
creating this mesh class to wrap the
vertex
data it's going to do just a few simple
things you'll need to define some data
let's say we'll make a cube so that we
need to define a bunch of position data
and we'll need to define some index data
the mesh class will also need to send
the data to opengl to upload to the gpu
which means we need to create buffers
for each data stream and then actually
buffer the data
you can see this function does exactly
that creates a buffer and follows that
with the
buffer data call we do make a
distinction here between normal vertex
data and indices
it's not perfect but it'll work don't
really want to get too hung up on detail
since i'm in a hurry
lastly this needs to bind the buffers
when we go to draw this thing
so we have this bind function here and
all it does is binds the various buffers
that make up this 3d object
in our case it's just positions and
indices but later we'll include other
data like normal and tangent data as
well
oh and we'll also need to draw can't
really do it much without that so
luckily it's just a couple lines we
can't really see if this works yet
because we need a material of some kind
to assign there
so let's get a shader material thing
going first thing we need to do is go
and create a shader class
and it'll be a simple class with just a
few basic responsibilities
it needs to take the vertex and fragment
source code it needs to compile them
and then it needs to get some data back
from the compiled source
about where the buffers and uniforms are
bound
so we have these load calls which when
you look inside the function definition
they just take the source and type of
program
they create a shader send the source
code then we compile it
and this block of code here all it does
is checks if everything succeeded or not
and
if it didn't it dumps it out on the
console anyway that means that we'll
need to define a simple shader too
what we'll do here is just to find some
colors for each side of the cube first
so
go back to the mesh class and define a
few colors and then buffer them
now in our shader here we don't need to
do that much
the vertex shader needs to transform the
position which means we need some
uniforms to define the world
view and projection matrices we'll pass
the vertex color via the varying
attribute down to the fragment shader
and we'll output the vertex color
multiplied by the texture directly as
the fragment output
what this means is we'll need a way to
bind the uniform values and supply them
to the shader
so this bind function in the shader will
do just that it just sets the uniforms
we need
that also means we need to actually load
a texture so let's
also do that we'll create this quick
texture class with a load function
and this is almost copy pasted straight
out of the mozilla docs
we have a simple load function followed
by some bind and unbind methods
now let's add a shader to the mesh class
so inside the bind function when we go
to bind the mesh we also bind the shader
that way when we're ready to draw the
mesh we have all the specific shader
data
so now we draw and there we go cube
there doesn't look like much so let's go
back into code and make it spin a bit
so you can see that it's a cube we'll
add some quick methods to expose
things like position and rotation to the
mesh class here and now that just means
that we need to add rotation to the
model matrix
we'll do that right here in the render
function for now and when we load it up
we have a spinny cube thing
we're definitely making a lot of
progress here even though it doesn't
seem like we have
anything up and this is all pretty
trivial so we have a mesh
and we have a shader now the problem is
if i wanted to find a second cube
with a second shader it's totally
possible i could just write
that right here in the renderer like
this and it would work
but remember the shader class also
compiles the source
and the mesh class creates a new set of
buffers so this is all super wasteful
what we want is to make a distinction
between the source and an instance
we'll create two new classes mesh
instance and shader instance
and what these will do is represent a
specific instance of an object
in the world think of it as the
difference between a blueprint of an
object
and actual instances in the world with
their own position rotation
that kind of thing so we have these two
new classes mesh instance and shader
instance
let's look at what they need to do mesh
instance needs its own
shader instance since it'll need to set
its own uniform values
it also needs to track position rotation
scale with functions to be able to set
those
finally we need a way to set up the draw
call so we need to create a bind
function that sets up the various
matrices and also binds the mesh data
itself
the shader instance class is also going
to be slightly different from the shader
class
what it needs to do is make a copy of
all the uniform values from the shader
but the key difference here is that
we'll also have the value
that needs to be set so then in the bind
function we can just loop over each of
the uniforms and we can set each one
nothing super complicated in here
there's just one small gacha with the
textures and that you need to manage the
texture index yourself so we just keep a
texture index variable here that gets
incremented with every texture that gets
bound
so now back to where we wanted to define
a second cube
now we can do that easily by defining a
couple of mesh instances and just
repositioning them apart
there we go got a couple of spinny cubes
might seem like a lot of work for little
gain
again but you've got the bones in place
for so much more now
so we've got some things drawing we need
to start building out the actual
renderer
the first thing we need to do is create
some fbos or frame buffer objects
these just seem to be opengl's way of
supporting render targets
but you know difficult to use because
opengl
so we'll go to find some fbos let's make
this init g buffer function
so we need to go and create that what
you need to do is create a bunch of
textures so
we define the depth buffer normal
texture here and the normal texture will
be a floating point texture instead of
the usual 8-bit
rgba we'll make it the same width and
height as the window
and then down here we'll create a frame
buffer and attach the various textures
to it
we'll need to make a slight change to
the render function at this point
now we need to use this bind frame
buffer and draw buffers calls to set up
the frame buffer
and now we'll draw out all the normals
for the scene and this didn't work i
just got a black screen
it's a bunch of spew in the console
about frame buffer incomplete
knew that my lack of error checking
would come back to bite me
anyway ended up googling around for a
while and screwing around
probably for an hour or two since i have
no idea what frame buffer incomplete
means
other than i've screwed up something to
do with the frame but for object
creation
obviously after consulting stack
overflow and various other sources it
turns out that you need to do a somewhat
magical call to enable floating point
textures with this line
gl dot extension xt color buffer float
after that things work fine i can write
the normals to the buffer and bind and
use that texture
so to do lighting properly i need to
reconstruct the world space position
inside the fragment shader so i need a
way to do that using the data from the
zed pre-pass
normal pass it's actually not super hard
to recreate it from the depth buffer but
i just wasted a bunch of time screwing
around with getting just
fbos working and i'm i wasn't confident
about getting the depth reads working
quickly
so i opted for a second texture that
just stored the positions
so we go back to the fbo definition and
we define a second floating point
texture for world space positions and
then we bind it to the frame buffer
object
now just a small change to the render
function and we'll change the shader to
also output position
and i ended up with this it wasn't
working again
normals are working fine but the world
space position
isn't i thought this was going to be
easier than getting the depth buffer
reads working but right now it's not
looking good
i'll save you all the debugging steps
but it turns out i just missed an s here
so that was a total waste of time this
is what it should look like
the next step is generating the light
buffer and in light pre-pass this is
just a pass that takes in the normal and
position
and accumulates the lighting
contribution in a new buffer
so we loop over the lights and then we
draw a screen space quad
down here in the fragment shader is
where the real work is done depending on
which light we're using
we read the normal position textures and
then we calculate the lighting
contribution at that point on the screen
that's a simple n dot l for the diffuse
and then the blinn fong specular uses
the normal
halfway vector raised to an exponent i
just hard coded one here because i'm
trying to get this done
i'll come back around if i have time and
since we're using just one buffer for
the lighting the specular color isn't
preserved and we only have the intensity
in the w component
once we do that we can output the light
buffer to confirm it's all working and
we've got some lighting on the scene
adding more lights it's just a matter of
blending them additively onto the buffer
so if we enable blending and set the
blend function to 1 1
then we can define a whole bunch of
lights and suddenly the scene is full of
lights
the last step we need to go back and add
one more pass
this is the opaque pass where we
actually draw the objects with their
textures and whatever else
this means going back and defining yet
another frame buffer object and creating
the textures that it needs
these don't have to be floating point
textures at this point and
in fact we could just draw directly to
the main frame buffer and not use an fbo
but i'll use a frame buffer object with
floating point textures because we could
potentially
tack on some post effects or tone
mapping or something like that
now it's a matter of looping through
each mesh instance again and drawing
them
but last time we did this all the meshes
are put normal in position
and this time we need them to use a
different shader
which means we need each mesh to support
having multiple shaders so we need to
make some small changes around here
we'll add this parameter to the bind
function that lets you specify which
pass you're doing
then when we create a mesh instead of
passing in a single shader instance
we'll pass in a dictionary with multiple
shader instances
and it'll be keyed off the past name so
here we
create a mesh instance and it'll have a
path called zed and that uses the zed
shader and then it'll have another pass
called color and that uses whatever
shader was specified in the parameters
this is what the color shader will look
like it's a simple shader that samples
the screen space light buffer and
multiplies it against the diffuse
texture
now when we go render we specify what
paths we're doing so the mesh knows
which shader to bind
and we have a whole bunch of spinny
cubes up with lights moving around the
scene randomly
everything kind of looks wet because the
specular but whatever i'm
making the tech not the art at this
point we're mostly done
this isn't efficient and a whole lot of
things could be done a zillion times
better
i ended up going back and instead of a
full screen quad
i switched this to add a set squad size
for light
and ended up burning the rest of my
evening screwing around with this
the whole point here is if you have a
light on the screen you don't need to
render the entire screen
to get that light's influence you can
just render
a small quad so if you can figure out
the screen space
extents of that quad then you can just
render a small quad and be done
for this demo it really made no
difference whatsoever but i thought i
could squeeze it in
but i couldn't i tried projecting the
light center to screen space
then from view space calculating up and
right and using the radius
and then getting a bounding box from
that but i kept getting a cut off light
so something was going wrong maybe i'd
been sitting at my laptop way too long
maybe it was because i was also drinking
beer at this point but anyway
finally found my error the next day my
quad was only half
size so i needed to multiply by two yeah
that's where things ended up not gonna
lie this is one steaming pile of code
not the greatest but it works sort of
and maybe
if you wash this all the way through
maybe you got something out of it
source code is available like always go
browse it on github
i promise i remembered it upload this
time look i even put it in the video as
proof
leave a comment tell me what you thought
and what should i work on next
cheers